next questions about the qualifications
you do in school and how you can
optimize your chances of getting into
Oxford or Cambridge
firstly what GCSE should I be doing and
how many this is a difficult trade-off
do fewer subjects and you will do very
well in a small number but do too many
and you will perform averagely across a
large number and personally I think that
anything between eight and eleven GCC's
is about the right number to be doing
that this will vary pretty wild leave a
person-to-person also it will depend on
how many GCSEs your school will allow
you to take but generally if you are
nearly or actually maxing out the number
of GCSEs that you can physically take
then you'll be just fine
in terms of choosing GCSEs this depends
on whether you have already chosen a
subject or not if you haven't chosen a
subject that you're going to be going to
university for as we're the case for
most people before GCSEs then simply
choose the subjects that you're most
interested in this will allow you to
pursue a subject which is closely
aligned with your interests and if you
have chosen a subject then check out
this link for Oxford and this link for
Cambridge for more information about
your course each course has a list of
required a levels so make sure that
you're choosing GCSEs that will allow
you to take those n levels secondly what
GCSE grades do I need to get it now the
obvious answer to the question is that
you shouldn't be worrying about what you
need and simply doing the absolute best
that you can do
however Oxford and Cambridge do use
GCSEs and a-levels slightly differently
in their admissions process on the one
hand Oxford uses GCSEs as a key factor
in determining who gets called to
interview you can check out this
interview I did with a college official
on this subject
well Cambridge uses UMS scores from a s
levels as a more important selection
criterion in Oxford's case then you
ideally want to be looking at a stars
and a's across a large number of
subjects the key thing is making sure
that you get a stars in subjects which
are directly related to the agree that
you will be applying for and while
obviously a stars across the board is
very ideal case but it's very possible
to get into Oxford with slightly lower
grades across the rest of your subjects
though the requirement of getting any
stars in the subjects to really relate
to what you're applying for remains keep
in mind that if you are from an
underperforming school then your GCSEs
will be considered relative to the
average performance of a candidate
at your school and if you're from of a
severely underperforming school then you
will likely be flagged in the omission
system and will be more likely to
receive an interview offer what
Cambridge doesn't use GCSE grades to the
same extent as Oxford it does still form
a part of their selection criteria you
can check out more information about how
they choose their students here and one
thing to know from this documentation is
that Cambridge only considers the eight
top eight GCC's that they do they
allocate your score based on how you
perform the GCSE but they only consider
your best eighth grade so doing more
than eight GCC's just increases the
chance that you'll do well on that
system but it's not necessary again you
obviously want to be doing very well
across the board but it's not such a big
deal in applying to Cambridge with
slightly lower GCSE grades than if you
were applying to Oxford thirdly what a
level should I be doing now as I
mentioned in the answer to the first
question intersection both Oxford and
Cambridge have links here and here which
describe what a levels are required to
get on to a degree course now obviously
you want to do these subjects or the
equivalent and other qualifications and
if you have any option blocks remaining
then choose subjects which you're
interested in or if you think they might
possibly be helpful to you during your
degree and I'd also like you to at least
consider doing the extended project
qualification if it's available to you
it's a great way of demonstrating some
of the qualities that the mission's
tutors are looking for and if you can
find a project as well suited to you it
can be really fun fourthly what about IB
and other qualifications in this video I
referred to a levels extensively purely
because that's the qualification most
applicants also decay MIT will be doing
but it's worth explicitly stating the
Oxford and Cambridge treat candidates
who've done the IB or other
qualifications just as seriously as
those who have taken a levels this also
applies to international qualifications
such as the SAT more information about
how Oxford views qualifications check
here and for Cambridge check here and
here for how they view both national and
international qualifications lastly what
a level grades do I need to get in
realistically you want to be aiming for
a star AAA level to be competitive
now while triple-a offers are still out
there and made all the time in order to
be truly competitive I'd recommend that
you aim for least a star AAA now while
some courses do
our a star a star a offers these are
relatively mercifully rare the a-level
requirements are listed on each courses
webpage which I've already linked in
addition to a level grades bear in mind
that Cambridge also use your math scores
from AAS levels as part of their
admissions criteria for more information
about this check out this link which is
a rather complicated summarize here but
the rather it is that you want to be
getting as high marks as possible in
each module as well as in the your
overall subject grade